hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
this thing that is going on right now
right this very second as you're
listening to my voice in some device
is enabled by technology right there
were no podcasts 20 years ago when i was
a kid we didn't have your podcast and so
forth
the internet cyberspace whatever you
want to call it has enabled
an enormous number of ways that people
can
communicate with or act each other
that were simply unheard of before you
have not only podcasts you have youtube
videos you have social media
you have blogs and online magazines and
so forth
the ability to communicate one way or
the other
is vastly larger the capacity i should
say vastly larger than it ever has been
before
this does not as many of you will be
familiar with
necessarily mean that the quality of
communication
has gone up in fact it's very clear
that in some cases in some circles in
some circumstances
this ability to communicate has been
used to what we would think of as
nefarious ends to not communicate
accurately or even good things but to
spread racism spread disinformation to
uh recruit people into extremist groups
and so forth the radicalization
of people from facebook and youtube is a
common theme that we hear about in the
media these days
so with today's guest roderick graham we
talk about
this tricky intersection of cyberspace
and difficult social conversations
roughly speaking the podcast falls into
two parts we talk first about
some of the research that rod has done
on cyberspace and
cyber bullying sex trafficking
ways that cyberspace has been used
against
people and then ways that oppressed
groups
groups that believe they're oppressed
often correctly have been able to fight
back in some sense rod is a techno
optimist about these things he's very
clear
that technology has been used for bad
ends but he's
hopeful that it can be used for good
ends and it is being used for good ends
that people can find
each other online in ways that they
couldn't before that
groups of uh not just minorities in the
sense of racial or ethnic minorities but
tiny groups of people who would have
been lost in a wider society before can
find each other
in ways they never could have in the
second part of the conversation which is
related i think
we talk about the idea that minority
groups of people in particular
can be oversimplified by other groups in
sort of how they think about them in
particular
the example that we think about is how
minority groups such as black americans
latino americans and so forth
can be more culturally or socially
conservative
than you might guess from their economic
progressivism
and that's an important factor to keep
in mind if you want to have
productive conversations we we saw this
in the 2020 election that
you cannot treat these groups of people
as big homogeneous blobs they're
different from each other
someone in the same economic
circumstances is going to be in
different social circumstances
if they are of different races different
ethnicities and they react to those in
different ways
so how do you reconcile being a little
bit culturally conservative a little bit
socially
or economically liberal and so forth so
these are all
to the goal of having better
conversations having better
conversations online
in person harnessing these powers that
have been given to us
by technology to make our interpersonal
communication a little bit better
a little bit more productive a little
bit more nuanced than it has been
before so i think it's a very important
interesting conversation rod has
many online interventions of his own
he's on twitter he has a wonderful
youtube page that you can check out
where he interviews people and he gives
little short
youtube videos by himself so check that
out all in the
like i said the goal of making
conversations
better before we go let me just mention
something i keep forgetting to mention i
want to which is that you know we have a
web page for the mindscape podcast
preposterous universe.com
podcast and the reason i bring it up is
because there's a lot of goodies there
such as complete transcripts for every
episode this is
something that is essentially supported
by the patreon supporters we have enough
money to
pay a transcription service to write
down every word so
very often if you want to search you can
search the mindscape podcast archives
for words and you will get every word
that has ever appeared in every
transcript of every of the episodes
we're an episode 136 now
not including all the bonuses and so
forth there's a lot to search through
if you're uh i don't know if you're
bored if you don't have anything to do
but or if you're
if you want to think to yourself like
where do we talk about the measurement
problem of quantum mechanics
things like that it's all there on the
webpage preposterousuniverse.compodcast
uh and that's enough of that with that
let's go
[Music]
welcome to the mindscape podcast hi
thanks for having me
let me begin this with a little bit of a
preamble because
you know this is a slightly different
topic than what we usually do although
who knows because we do so many
different topics
um you know you what you do for a living
uh it seems to involve hot button issues
over and over again right you know
racism especially but also
issues about the internet and social
media that people
have emotional opinions about and i just
wonder how that
makes you feel in your everyday life in
the sense that you know i can ignore
many of these issues i can choose not to
talk about them partly because
i'm white right this is an aspect of
white privilege but also partly because
i'm a physicist so i could if i wanted
to
ignore these kinds of issues and but i
think it's important to talk about them
even though i know for a fact ahead of
time that no matter what we actually say
the uh percentage of likes on the
youtube version of this will be lower
than average just because we're talking
about
issues that are very very sensitive so
that's true as a
as a professional who does this like do
you ever feel like
wow i'm just exhausted by doing this all
the time i mean it's not just your
everyday life it's your professional
life as well
uh well you know what no uh not at this
point i really didn't start doing this
until
after i knew that i would um gain tenure
okay so even even though i was talking
about
race uh it was it was really couched
within
technology right and the way that i
would talk about it
wasn't uh in any way that would make
anyone go up in arms it was really about
how
racial minor minorities particularly
black americans could use technology to
improve their lives so um and then i
started talking about cyber crime in
general and and how to protect
uh uh computers and and mobile phones so
it was it was not uh
any hot button issues really until the
last year or two that i really started
doing this
and that's in a more sort of public
intellectual vein
in uh writing up ads and being on
twitter and things like that
that's right that's right and it was an
intentional choice i i felt that uh
i don't know i was losing a little
meeting from um
doing what i was doing i felt like i was
gonna be stuck if i just
just just tried to produce research and
who was gonna read that you know so i
i said well let me try something else
that's kind of how it started yeah yeah
and it actually makes sense to me i
think that there is
uh there seems to be a connection but
let's start with um
that that old school research you were
doing back before a year ago
uh you're a sociologist i think i think
you're the first sort of card-carrying
sociologist we've had
on the podcast um is it accurate to say
that uh the internet and social media
and cyberspace where the focus are the
focus of your
professional research it is even
even when i get around to doing research
now certainly yes yes it started with
dealing with racial minorities then it
migrated uh
to deviance online and so now i
i guess i would say okay i'm studying uh
cyber crime online yeah
cyber crime online so i mean this is
even though you said it wasn't this is a
hot button issue right i mean
people really worry about the effects of
cyberspace on the kids today
and you know the overall discourse and
extremism
um i mean have you found in your
research any
clarity on on the big questions of
whether or not
the flourishing of social media and
cyberspace more generally
has made us better or worse
communicators people citizens
uh fellow people it's an interesting
question i guess when i first started
doing this i
i was one of those uh
utopians you know i thought that okay
and there are a lot of folks out here
who think that technology is always a
positive or generally a positive and i
was one of those i guess i still am a
little bit
but i don't know i mean given what's
been going on
over the last year or so i wonder when i
first started
doing this i guess uh 10 years ago it
was it was important
for disadvantaged groups and
marginalized groups to have a voice
and so the internet provided that uh
and uh and we and we could see it you
know it was it was very visible you
could say all of a sudden
not just black americans who i'm
focusing on but also women native
americans
uh and hispanics uh and in the queer
community they were able to get their
their words out through
uh social media and so yeah in that way
it's great
but i mean these days you know you've
got
people you know running off into their
echo chambers
and you know you've got information
flows that uh
you could just say their disinformation
flows they're just not accurate
yeah and people are consuming those
things and so now you wonder
if it's uh if it's a positive uh or not
well what does it mean to do research in
these kinds of areas i mean
there's no shortage of punditry about
these things uh
so as the first sociologist we've had on
here like what what is your day-to-day
when you're
trying to be scholarly about these
questions
well i guess i could talk about my
research now it's kind of weird because
it
the the listener would be like well this
guy started with uh
african-americans he mentioned of
um disinformation now he's going to talk
about sex work but uh
the the research that i'm actually doing
right now is about uh
deviance online so for this particular
research
i'm i'm doing a a sort of uh empirical
quantitative piece
where i'm trying to establish some
overall human behavior patterns online
and then i'm doing a more interpretive
piece which is important for
sociologists because you want to get
some sense of of of how people are
living in their worlds the meanings
they're associated with things it can be
a little gooey and icky
uh i'm i know i'm speaking to a
physicist so it has to
seem that way it's very imprecise you
know you can't put it in numbers but
it's important
so um with this particular research i'm
trying to understand how
men are using
an online sex work forum okay
it is a kind of a hot button issue
because right now it's illegal in the
united states to put
sex work to sell sex online
and so this site is in uh the uk
and i'm studying this there because i've
got my thumb to the wind and i feel like
in a couple years this will be something
that will be a part of the public
discourse a lot of
sex workers are would like to be able to
uh
apply their trade and they and they and
they can't and so
i want to look at the uk where it's a
little easier for them to do that
and try and then make an analogy to what
might happen in the u.s if that makes
any sense
it does and so i'm sorry i just would
say it seems like a
kind of good what a biologist would call
a model organism in the sense that you
know we can study this and try to get
implications for elsewhere right i mean
it's one of those
examples sex work where something's a
little bit taboo and you can ask how
this new thing called social media is
going to change our opinions about that
that's right that's right and so the the
quantitative piece
for that is um i did something uh that's
a
called a sentiment analysis where uh you
use a web crawler and you collect the
words from a website
and then those words generally speaking
um
have emotional valences so positive
negative
and so uh once you collect the words uh
you you simply do
a type of summative uh count and you get
a sense of
whether or not men are talking about
women
and just sex work in general in a
positive way or negative way
there are other types of emotions
they're not in my head right now but
those are the two broad poles positive
and negative
and so um that's one way and i've
already done that part and
i mean it it's a very positive thing
it's not as if
so many uh anti-sex work folks in the
u.s are saying like this is going to
further objectify women that this will
this will lead to uh some type of sexism
um and so the idea
is for me to see if that's actually
happening in the uk and on this
particular website i don't i don't see
that
that's that's very interesting because
we all know that there is sort of a
double-edged sword aspect to this kind
of uh
unfettered frontier of the internet
where people can say anything they want
and so what you're saying is
it's actually not completely lord of the
flies people are behaving a little bit
better than we might
fear yes yes and it might be that
that a lot of those fears just aren't
grounded in any actual
actual evidence right so
all the research that i've done or read
prior to this
show that uh it's very little um
it's not as if you have a lot of men who
are
one looking to um be violent towards
women to objectify women
and then going and and finding a sex
worker to do that that does happen of
course but
that's just not the general pattern or
two
after they leave uh a sex work
experience
uh do they all of a sudden become um the
types of people who
would then objectify women that's not
what i've seen um it's a bit i'm not
halfway through this research and i've
got some more things to read but
i don't see that at all so that so the
quantitative part is the collecting that
the words
but now i have to go through and read
the conversations online and try and
interpret
in a in a more nuanced way what men are
talking about
yeah this seems to be my impression of
how a lot of sociological research is
done that it's a back and forth
between kind of the more quantitative
but
kind of blunt instrument approach and
then a more
qualitative but you can go in there and
look at individual words and testimonies
and try to see how that
matches with the quantitative picture
that's right
yes yes that's a good way of describing
it
if you want a home fitness solution that
combines inspiration
and fun with structure and getting the
work done
the peloton cycle is for you peloton is
extremely convenient it's right there in
your house
but it also provides you enough
structure to have someone there
telling you to reach your higher goals
one of the great things that i've
noticed about being on the peloton bike
is the curated music selection they have
epic artist collaborations with
instructor curated playlists
so their music experience is unlike any
other whether you're in the mood for
some hip hop
pop country the peloton bike has the
right music to keep you entertained and
motivated all year long
and it's not just a cardio workout you
can add a strength class to your ride
or combine cardio and strength in one
workout with bike boot camp
to get a total body fitness experience
there are classes for every level from
beginner programs to tabata intervals
peloton meets you at every step in your
fitness journey
so to get started on your peloton
journey go to onepeleton.com to learn
more that's
o-n-e
to learn more this extends i guess to
other things besides sex work i know you
worked on
cyber bullying this is something where
again there's a bunch of uh
fear about it uh do you think that
the internet or social media do give
people a new and effective way to bully
others or is it just sort of something
that's been going on all along
uh well the last time i looked at the
bullying rates kids report bullying
offline still more than online
okay but but yes but yes it does it does
happen it does happen
um from what from what i understand
we've
as a the scholars who study this we've
coalesced around some
parameters for when bullying is really
bullying so it's it's not just
you know someone saying something nasty
about you online that doesn't have the
effects the negative effects that that
uh we often see with cyber bullying
dropout rates
uh using alcohol drugs you know some
emotional problems
it has to be some some some uh some
things in place and
so one of those would be it's got to be
repeated um
a second is that there needs to be a
power differential
where the person being bullied feels
that they have no agency
to to do anything about it uh and then
third it it
it has to be perceived as bullying
okay so if in other words if a parent
sees some
some words online about uh you know kids
talking about
her kid it doesn't matter if if her kid
thinks that it's funny
right it has to be a perception of
bullying so those three things matter
and when you get those three things
then you get those negative side effects
so that does happen
yeah and does this kind of research
suggest things we should do about it i
mean how how
how engaged are you with the sort of
policy prescription side of things
uh a few times i've done some public
talks about cyber bullying
and the
main way of dealing with this is just
education of the parents sometimes
parents go a little over
overboard with it also educators
can can perform types of interventions
mainly by dealing with the bystanders so
if you can get bystanders to say no
this is not good and don't pile on then
then that
deals with cyberbullying quite a bit and
then that agency part is important
so if kids know that they have someone
to talk to
then that gives them a sense that they
can do something about it the worst
thing is to just say oh just suck it up
you know or just ignore it right so in
some sense it's it's it's
an example of the idea that you should
fight speech with more speech
right you could fight cyber bullying
with you know cyber
help or you know cyber neighborliness or
something like that
oh yeah that's a good way of putting it
and and
we're talking we're having this
conversation at a time when
there's been a lot of recent
conversation about free speech
on the internet and um on social media
platforms
in particular because some very
well-known people have gotten kicked off
of social media platforms um what does
your research teach you about
the pluses and minuses of completely
unfettered speech or do you think that
there are
sensible ways to keep things in line or
is that just a losing proposition
i don't do any research on that i mean i
have some uh
some standard i think sociological
understandings of the harms of free
speech
i don't know where you stand on this but
there are a lot of folks who think that
uh
they're sort of free speech absolutists
right where it's like you know just
let everyone talk and the best idea will
bubble up or as you said combat bad
speech with good speech this this type
of thing i'm actually not
that way um for for
historical reasons i mean i i think that
people in the past have
been able to use speech to denigrate
groups
and so that that has to be understood
and we have to take that into account
um and and so that's one reason and then
a second reason is because of the
i guess because of the cyber willing
research i mean i know that speech can
can hurt sometimes when i'm online i'll
i'll when i want to poke
the bear a little bit i'll say you know
speech is violence
or words are violence and then and then
that that usually attracts some people
and
that gives me a chance to do uh back and
forth but but i'm not just being silly i
think that words
uh can hurt and and so i think we have
to take that into account when we try
and understand free speech
so i've never i don't think i've ever
sort of written or even opined about
this in any systematic way but
i completely agree that that speech can
be violence
but i'm also kind of a free speech
absolutist um in the sense that
if people want to talk and other people
want to listen to them
i think that should always be allowed
but i don't think you should be forced
to listen
to things you don't want to listen to
i'm not sure if that makes me an
absolutist or not
i don't know how how would you take uh
suppose
you know we've had these famous uh
incidents of
of controversial speakers wanting to go
on college campuses
that might happen more on on your side
of town than mine i'm at a working class
university so kids are aren't as uh
politicized but certainly i've seen it
online
uh you know the the speaker wants to
talk
um but the kids don't want to listen so
what do you do
what do you do in that case is that uh
are they justified in saying you know
don't talk or what i don't i don't know
yeah so my attitude is and again i'm
very
uh open to updating my attitudes about
this because they're not completely well
thought out
my attitude is if something like a
university
invites someone to give a talk then the
members of that university
the students the faculty whatever have
every right to
complain and say no don't do that we're
stakeholders here we didn't invite this
person
but if like a little club at the
university really
wants a speaker to come and they're not
forcing anyone else to come and listen
to it no one is is
necessarily uh invited even then i don't
think that
other people who are not in that club
have the right to shut it down
oh that makes sense that makes sense
it's really weird i mean if you if
if we were having this conversation four
years ago i would have
probably said oh you know let let the
person talk you know
because i grew up in that era where
words weren't seen as these uh
these these powerful weapons but as i
speak more with students and read more i
just i see it as just a change in a
a generational change right and and so
if
so i'm saying that i agree with you in
the in the abstract
but i i think that students young people
are perceiving the world in a different
way and and and so i'm i'm more
likely to respect their perceptions up
to a point sure
uh so so if they want to organize
and um and say look we don't want you on
this campus
okay i won't i won't stop that of course
if they want to pass a law to stop
someone to speak and that would be
different
yeah and actually i wouldn't i wouldn't
be against them
organizing and protesting but if i were
the organizer of the protest
i would say it's a protest against what
this person is saying
not a protest that tries to stop them
saying it
and and you know again this is where the
double-edged sword comes in right
because um
uh i i worry that if you try to
or if you if the norms change so that
people can say
well that set of people listening to
that speech
is itself bad even if they want to
listen to it
that that kind of attitude will be used
against uh
fights for justice and and trying to
make the world a better place it's it's
you know it's the
people who are not in positions of power
who are ultimately going to be
more uh deleteriously affected by that
yeah i can see that yeah that makes a
lot of sense so how does this come about
how does this play into
um the social media conversation about
race which i know that uh
we are going to get to um i mean i have
my opinions about this i think everyone
listens to
uh punitry about it but in your view how
do you how do you conceptualize
social media as used by racists and
anti-racists or non-racists oh those
conversations are
are terrible they're these bullet point
so i don't listen to uh racists that
much i don't know they're
they're sort of hidden they're not in my
uh network so i don't i don't know much
about
about that but even the even the
activists who are attempting to use
a lot of the ideas from academia
and use a lot of the words that bubble
up out of academia
their their heart is in the right place
so i'm with them in spirit but not
always in mind
because they're they're flattening these
very difficult terms
and then using them to uh explain why
they want social change
so it's it's a bit weird i mean i i i
do talk a lot about some of the words
that you and your audience would know
of white privilege white fragility these
types of things
and um i realized that you know
when i say those things i i have like
this iceberg
like the bottom of the iceberg that i
taking with me when i'm talking and
no one can see that and no one can know
it and twitter with her was it 250
characters or something yeah it's
really hard to to get those things out
and so um and then i'm coming in line
behind several other people who've
just simply said okay you have white
privilege you know be quiet
which is not the right way to go so you
got people who are acculturated to
responding to the bullet points
and me trying to use a slightly more
nuanced bullet point
yeah and it just it just kind of uh goes
downhill i have to say though
um i have been able to to develop some
pretty
rewarding conversations with people
after i do the
the blocking and the muting and the
focusing on certain folks
who are not anti-racists right they
don't like
the way that uh a lot of these ideas are
used
but they also want racial equality and
they're also concerned about transphobia
they're also concerned about sexism they
just
don't articulate their concerns or see
the way forward
in this or in this current you know
anti-racist zeitgeist i guess
right i mean i guess we can
skip forward a little bit this was all
my list of things i wanted to talk about
but
uh you're bringing up the idea that
there can be productive
conversations even online even even in
the
very limited domain that twitter gives
you and i think that sometimes that gets
lost in hot button issues because
the noisy voices that might be very
blunt
and non-nuanced drown everything else
out right and
it's it's difficult to sort of screen
those away
and try to have a productive
conversation with someone who disagrees
with you
but in a potentially productive way
that's true that's true and and there's
a i mean the bigger your
twitter account is and yours is uh quite
large uh it it it becomes almost
impossible
so mine is a moderate size it's a it's
it's not that not that big so i can
identify people who i've been having
conversations with for quite a while
and we're not really bothered that much
after the first flurry of replies
go down and we can have a nice uh back
and forth you know
in between cooking dinner it's not bad
and this is something where you would
say
in your tech optimist persona uh that
has been
enabled by social media like you
wouldn't be talking to these people
otherwise right
that's correct that is correct uh so in
that way it's been
it's been wonderful i mean maybe this is
not a research level question but do you
have advice
for people out there on social media
about how to engage with people you
disagree with
i do and i don't i don't follow these
rules all the time but
yes i do i i think that people tend to
respect respect
so um especially in an era where there's
so much
disrespect you stand out so
um when i had a really small account and
i was like okay i'm going to communicate
social science now i started out
as so respectful people are like whoa
this is refreshing
because i would have these kind of back
and forth then i would try and explain
things
and then what would happen is those
more and more voices would come on who i
thought were very uh that were kind of
communicating in bad faith and
the anonymous accounts and whatnot and
so they would wash out
i mean they would just beat all that
respectfulness out of you and so you
just would
you know i i became a bit more course
but but i still like to communicate with
people and
if you can speak if you can maintain
that sort of level
of uh respectability uh in good faith
discussion uh people will latch on to
that
yeah no i think that's really really
important but i think probably the most
important
thing in my mind of what you just said
is just emphasizing how hard
it is uh to me social media are
wonderful in many ways but they're just
such natural places to be
snarky and short and extremist
and like constantly reminding yourself
to sort of engage with
the potentially good parts is hard and i
try to do it i'm not very good at it and
i'm trying to get better
right even though i can't understand
what you would be saying that would
cause someone to
say anything uh negative but
yeah i mean i guess there's nothing you
can say on twitter when you have enough
people
following you that they'll all agree
with
well it's very strange there are people
who are very emotional about the
multiverse or quantum mechanics but
it does not compare to racism or sexism
or things like that and i will i'll
sometimes comment on those and then you
add a
you got to block some people and decide
who else is worth talking to
yeah yeah i agree there's uh this
twitter is you know
anonymous or you can be anonymous and
that just naturally leads to changes in
behavior i think i think psychologists
call it de-individuation or something
disinhibition one of the two or maybe
both and so it's just a
it's just a natural thing when you can
be anonymous and communicate with a
thousand other people
that you you're just gonna be nastier
yeah and what is your opinion about the
idea that
some of the algorithms on social media
either intentionally or unintentionally
drive people towards more extreme
content maybe just to get more
clicks this seems to be from the
research i've seen you know a real
phenomenon that maybe we should worry
about
for a long time even even from the uh so
you're talking about twitter now
but i can remember you know several
years ago
people were complaining about the google
uh search algorithm showing different
results
based upon your prior results or who
they think you are or something
i on the one hand i'm like look those
are private companies they should
they should be able to do what they want
on the other hand there are some
negative consequences to that
i think it does produce uh some negative
i've seen
several research projects which looked
at
like the effects of uh how long someone
has been on twitter uh
or social media and then their their
views and uh
i mean i think it's it's pretty clear i
hope someone doesn't listen to this and
say no he's wrong but i think it's
pretty clear that uh
consuming a lot of social media does
make you more polarized
so that's a problem um it could be that
the public outcry to these things has
led to a lot of these
uh social media companies uh changing
the way they do things i like the way
that
that twitter now has that news fact
check thing that pops up when you want
to retweet a
a news um a news story and i think
that's wonderful
i think that those types of things over
time will have us
uh tame this technology yeah i think
that there are strategies and that is a
an encouraging thing i was actually even
more than twitter thinking about
facebook or youtube where you know there
are recommendations for things to read
and we all know the more extreme stuff
is is more likely to get clicked on and
uh and capitalism gets in the way of
trying to fix that but it's something we
should probably keep in mind
yeah that's right that's right uh on the
other hand if i may
throw a little counter example up there
i spent some time
in the the manosphere on on youtube it's
it's these
uh channels that cater to men and and um
i think men's spaces are are needed and
so i was like well let me let me
listen to these male youtubers and
they've got all types of
acronyms that they use to describe
themselves mgtow
and i forget some of these other men
going their own ways what that means
and all these different types of self
identifications so um about a year ago
people started complaining that okay
these sites are producing misogynistic
content
and i i think that they do i agree with
that to some extent
and if you start you know getting to
your point here if you start
watching one person talk about you know
how to be a man in 2020 or something
yeah it's going to lead you down a
rabbit hole to eventually
you know all women are bad you know
that's just going to happen
and so and so there the the the folks
who are complaining about this
uh had a point and so i started hearing
a lot of those male youtubers talk about
the great purge
about how youtube was going to
de-platform them
or demonetize them and a lot of them did
get demonetized and a lot of them had to
leave
uh youtube because of that and so i'm
saying all that because
it's a kind of a double-edged sword if
you say oh these algorithms are
are bad they're they're leading people
down these extremist rabbit holes
if you change those things all of a
sudden you're you're
in a way determining what what people
get
to watch right so it's either it's
either way you're gonna you're gonna do
the
algorithms to give them more stuff they
want or you're gonna do an algorithm
that doesn't right but either way it's
gonna be something right so it's uh
i don't know it's a it's a double a
sword i'm i'm in generally in favor of
of not the extremism i'm just kind of
playing with the idea here
um that you brought it up no i mean i
think it is it is very complicated and
subtle which is why my own views are not
very set in stone i mean i i would
i would rather let all these groups of
people
have their spaces to have their
discourse i think that's very very
important i mean maybe
the most important thing is to provide
alternatives where
you can talk about manliness or whatever
it is
in a way that does not ultimately lead
you to and women are bad
right and that's a lot more positive
strategy one could imagine taking but
also maybe
more difficult than just deleting some
accounts from youtube
right right right and on the others on
the flip side of things i think that
you've written about the idea of
uh black people in particular but maybe
other groups
um using uh putting social media to work
in a positive way right like organizing
finding each other in ways
that they couldn't do would you say that
there are senses in which social media
have been
forces for justice in recent years
sure um on balance i mean i i think that
minority groups have been able to use
social media
or leverage social media to a greater
extent than um
than um than majority groups i i think
so that that's my general take on things
so my early research had to do with
several
of these dynamics one was the ability to
get
uh ideas out from a sort of um
it's been a while since i went out since
i've used those terms
but it's a subspace of of ideas
you kind of develop those ideas as a
group
and then they become a part of the
mainstream
over time after they've been well
developed which is a kind of a
phenomenon where you you know someone
you you've got like a collection of
like black twitter is one of the the
prime examples right so you got some
some main people in that space and then
they
generate an idea about a problem in the
world right
and then other people in that space they
get to they get to see how that
how that problem is articulated and then
they talk with each other and they
refine that articulation um maybe saying
oh yeah you might be right about this
here's this study or you know here's
this
example and here's that example and and
through this kind of iterative process
you go from this
incoit idea uh to
possibly okay here is uh this is the
problem that we're having
and this is how we can deal with it and
these are the people who can talk about
it
i saw this with the uh the
[ __ ] movement well actually your
listeners might not know much about that
but
we certainly saw it with the black lives
matter movement right okay right so it
yeah
that would be the probably the prime
example
where it started i believe on facebook
uh and then and then
you know people were talking about
issues with police brutality there
and then and then it migrates to
facebook and it's not just saying you
know black
folk are being harassed by police or
being shot more
it's also having the examples it's also
understanding
you know how people will respond to that
and developing
ideas that way and so through that
through that back and forth
you end up getting this this general
idea that became uh quite important
in american society and the so now it's
my turn to be
slightly contrary and just for purposes
of asking questions uh
is the contrary worry that it leads to
splintering of the community or the
nation or whatever that people
go into their own little groups and
their own little identities
and lose some commonality
yeah that is a that is a concern um i'll
give you the standard
um critical theory
uh response uh critical theories are
really
quite a buzzword these days this is the
uh
the standard response and the response
would be that those groups are already
marginalized
and so you know you you
may be as a white male or someone who
has access to things you may see this
now
as being divisive but before those
groups
uh were already divided out if i mean
right think of it that way and so um
this is just them now
uh arguing for inclusion in the national
narrative
i'm not saying that's accurate or not
that's more of a theoretical way of
thinking about it
but um but that would be i guess the the
response from a lot of folks
i think that makes sense i mean a lot of
what gets passed off
as unity and agreement is actually just
silencing the people who would disagree
right and
uh maybe social media makes that harder
to do
yeah that's possible yes that's true
actually so let me let me double back a
little bit since we're talking about it
a lot of folks are now this is this is a
are concerned about this this cancel
culture and not the culture
we're talking about uh the the the uh
students on campus
but just online you know someone has a
uh
wants to develop a counter narrative to
this uh anti-racist thing or
or they have a different take on how we
should talk about
uh trans persons they are not able
to say that so so it might be that
those marginalized groups have now sort
of they have a symbolic weight
that me and a moral weight which which
now makes them a part of the national
narrative
but now they may be silencing uh
different voices on their own right i
don't i don't know
i mean yeah i think that this is uh i
mean we can talk about this more because
again i don't have
very fixed views about it and would love
to learn more
um clearly there's a couple of examples
just last week
where people who i thought pretty highly
of were fired from their jobs for
saying completely innocuous things on
twitter i think that's a real
phenomenon that happens on the other
hand i'm reluctant to
label it as a culture and i think that's
sort of a lazy shortcut
to um silence people who are trying to
critique bad
things so even will wilkinson who was a
previous
um mindscape guest i don't know if you
followed his story
did you follow his story by the way no i
didn't so bill wilkinson is a sort of
libertarian
think tank guy uh relatively middle of
the road
and uh he was making fun of the capital
insurrection by uh by putting a bad joke
on twitter where he said you know
maybe biden could unite the country by
lynching mike pence
since the uh the maga protesters wanted
to do that some of them anyway
now this might be very well uh
characterized as
a as a joke in bad taste but he got
fired from his job
at the think tank for that twitter joke
that he uh apologized for
and um to his credit he then wrote a
long article
saying uh you know yes i got fired this
is bad i think it's silly
but it's not cancel culture it's it's
lazy and reductive to call it cancel
culture
we should think about these things on a
case-by-case basis
so i'm a little skeptical of the idea
that there's a whole culture out there
of doing it rather than just
the eternal human uh tendency to
occasionally overreact and and cover
your ass in bad situations
that might be it uh it could be that as
you know as human beings we are
uh you know wired to to sort of connect
with others and then enforce
our groups uh norms i guess and um
if we see something out of the norm you
know we'll
we'll say something about it but this is
uh 2020 2021 now and so
instead of just saying oh you know laura
hadn't cut her grass
and and then just complained to the
neighbors you can now do that you know
you can now do that online
and a million people can then join in
and then all of a sudden your employer
has to
for damage control has to has to fire
you so it might just be a combination of
technology and human nature you're right
and i think that is a danger when you
can sort of amplify
these petty grievances into getting
people fired using social media but on
the other hand
i don't want to shut out criticism of
people when they say
bad things so it's it's you know it's
tough to be a critic
of cancer culture and also a free speech
absolutist even though those
those groups tend to often overlap in a
in a big way
but anyway good neither one of us has
the complete and final answer to that i
think we can admit those questions
but you mentioned this phrase critical
theory which is another one
which like you said has become a hot
button issue and
i'm not exactly sure why like i was an
undergraduate
in the 80s and a graduate student in the
90s and you know i had friends and i
took classes
where people talked about deconstruction
and the frankfurt school and critical
theory
and then it just disappeared i never
heard about it and suddenly this year
it's all over the place you know the the
administration is making proclamations
about it
so what is critical theory and how did
that happen
i don't know how it happened either but
but i i can kind of give a a
a broad overview of what critical theory
is so it's a
it's a branch or maybe a viewpoint
within social sciences that you know you
that starts with some assumptions that
uh there is
uh inequality in the world and it's due
to oppression so we know there's
inequality it's just
it's just a demonstrable it's just
demonstrated fact and so
they're assuming that it is because of
some type of
forms of oppression uh now we're talking
about racism but it doesn't have to be
it could be sexism
uh it could be heteronormativity it
doesn't it doesn't matter
and so uh the critical theorist
is their their task is to try and
understand the structures
in place in society that produce and
reproduce that oppression
and then dismantle those structures okay
and so for a lot of folks
that's that's scary because i mean if
you're happy with
uh with your life or even if you're not
entirely happy but you think that okay
you know things like um and i i should
back up a little bit and say that
uh some of the things that they that a
critical theorist would
would say is causing this oppression is
a
focus on objectivity and uh
meritocracy meritocracy on objective
science
even so not just just
just objective facts but this idea that
you can create some kind of knowledge
based on just objectivity
these ideas are individualism even
liberalism you know so they they want to
uh
you know critique those ideas and and
see
to the extent uh that they are
reproducing inequalities and oppression
and so that for a lot of folks can be
a little uh troubling right i mean if
you if you
believe as most people doing including
myself that you know look
there is a objective reality out there
um that uh
you know individualism is a lot better
than collectivism you know you have
these ideas
and then you hear someone comes along
and they say no you know these things
are bad and they're actually
creating um uh they're the cause of
racial inequality in society and and we
have to do something about it that
that's going to be a problem for a lot
of people
yeah and it's definitely one of the
examples where a slightly nuanced
take is almost necessary right because i
believe in the real world i believe in
objective reality and i would strongly
argue against anyone who
thought that the a conviction that the
objective real world exists is somehow
the tool of the oppressor
but i i am sympathetic to the idea that
the
rhetoric of objectivity and meritocracy
etc
can be used to paper over oppression and
discrimination right
so this is exactly one of these hot
button issues where it's just
hard to have that careful conversation
because everyone wants to
pick out the worst of what the other
side is saying and then highlight that
and forget about everything in between
that's right that's right and and from
that broad um
overview i guess i mean it's obviously
more more nuanced than that but but
that's what i can think of you didn't do
did we say we're going to talk about crt
because you know a lot of times people
want me to be that person to talk about
uh uh crt they can't seem to get
critical
so i said ct is critical theory and then
a branch of that is critical race theory
all right so often i'm asked to talk
about these things because they can't
get in
uh someone to talk about it but in any
case
yeah but um what often happens is it
gets distilled
uh into these these sort of
terms that have some i guess prima facie
validity
and you know it's like a it's like a
validity sandwich
so if you if you give the broad idea
so let's say white fragility there is
some validity in it
and then if you start talking about it
people are going to say wait a minute
this is
this is not falsifiable this is not uh
scientific
you know this is just divisive you know
and then they'll be right and then when
you sit in a class and you learn about
and you realize okay i know it makes
sense
that's that kind of that kind of
sandwich that's a problem
so i'm sure you've heard of um of white
fragility
this idea that if you try and talk about
race you know why folks go bonkers this
type of thing right
um propagated by robin d'angelo
okay and um this is definitely a
critical
uh theorist idea it's like okay white
folks have
uh been born into a society that has
inculcated these
racialized views in them and so they
need to be aware of that we need to be
aware of that and critique those things
and one way is to be aware of your
fragility
i don't know how useful that is i've had
some uh guests on my show to talk about
it but
but that that that sort of emblematic of
this of this approach
yeah and uh how does that relate
to the very common move that is made
that
to make real progress we should be
focusing on economics and class
and talking about identity or race or
gender is a distraction from those real
questions
well me personally i think that there
are class-based issues and they're
race-based issues
and um on a practical level
you know we are
a society has to come to has to
negotiate things so
if people are more willing to support
a class-based policy
um you know just dealing with poverty in
the united
because it will of states also benefit
uh people of color
but but if you want to really aim the
bullseye at a problem then you have to
deal with the issue that that underlies
it and so some of those things are
exclusively race-based issues
so you think of yourself as more or less
a pluralist along the dimensions that
are worth being critical about
that we should you know explore all
these different ways in which
uh things could be less than ideal in
society
um well i think i mean if
i don't know what you mean so you mean
as a critical like a critical scholar
and critique things or i mean i guess
you mean just
i mean i guess i i'm i think that and
maybe this is
a an incorrect um impression on my part
but
there seem to be some people who are
just reductive
about what is bad about society and how
to fix it right if we could just
make everyone have an equal income
everything would be fine
right or if we could just get rid of
racism everything would be fine and
it sounds like you're more open to
saying well no there's all these
problems and they're a little bit
different and we should think about all
of them
oh that's absolutely true i mean this is
a every
phenomenon in society is multicausal i
mean
it's always going to be the case that
there are several things involved and so
we just sort of select
the the three or four variables that
that explain the most variation i guess
and
and go with them and so i mean uh income
is
uh and wealth are like two of the main
ones and
um so that would be a way to go
um i i think that when it comes to
policing black communities are
over-policed and there are some ripple
effects from that that comes from
just the over-policing and so if we can
handle that that would be a good way to
go
so absolutely and can we say at the
level of data
that um if black communities are
over-policed et cetera
it it is not something that goes away if
we control for
poverty or or income or whatever it's
not just that poor communities are over
policed and
and black communities are often poor
it's really a separate thing that
black communities have this problem it's
two things so
um i think that
that if we would control for class we
would still see
that black folk in fact i'm sure of it
that we'll see that black communities
are police more
but i am not sure if that's even the
best analogy because it might be that
or the best way of thinking about it
because it might be that someone could
argue i think
uh accurately that the
the reason that they are police more is
because there's more crime there
so there's more crime one there's
there's more crime there at time one and
then and then
they're overpoliced that time too so so
i'm not
entirely sure if controlling for class
is that is that helpful i think instead
what we would have to do is look at the
um the ways that they're policed
realizing that poverty does in
in indeed create crime
but instead of having a a overly
punitive approach in those areas
uh come up with alternative ways to uh
deal with uh juvenile delinquency
to deal with uh like these low-level
drug offenses
um that really you're putting people in
jail for years and years and years
for for uh these minor offenses you know
these are
in even the uh relationships between
police and
and citizens uh that might need to be
some that might
have to be uh considered the classic
uh comparison uh that i'm sure you've
heard is that okay if you look at
um like there's a study done about
oakland and we know that there's more
drug
use in um the white side of oakland i
guess
i say we know i didn't know but i i read
this research
there's more drug use there but somehow
the police are all
all in the in the uh the black side of
town
and they end up arresting more people
for drugs well that
that that's a kind of a uh i mean you
can sort of say well that's a
a class issue but i'm not entirely sure
i think it's more that those police have
been there for decades there's this sort
of
uh understanding that okay this is where
the crime is and there is more violent
crime in those areas and so they end up
going into those areas and and maybe
they're dealing with the violet crime
but they're also
sopping up a lot of other deviants that
really should just be left alone
and those people then get in the system
and then you got this ripple effect
where they don't finish
high school um they they start to drop
out of society
and then they don't develop us they
don't get good jobs they don't start
strong families you know all this
down the line so this is why you know
the
cause and effect analysis is so
extraordinarily difficult in sociology
or economics and it's just much easier
to become a physicist
frankly how do you feel yeah i i i'm
sorry go ahead no i was gonna i was
gonna ask how do you feel about the
claim
that one is either racist or anti-racist
and there's sort of no in-between which
that's another hot-button thing that
people have been arguing about recently
on the the social media
yes yes they have so um
if i understand it correctly now right
and i listened to his uh you're talking
about ibrahim kennedy's book and yeah i
listened to his um
uh book how to be an anti-racist i
thought it was uh kind of interesting we
grew up
at almost the same time and so he speaks
about some of the things that i
i experienced but um the way i
understand it now
is that given a set
given a policy or an idea
that idea can either reproduce uh
an understanding that races are
different or it can
uh eliminate or mitigate the uh the
notion that races are different
given an idea and then a policy that's
about race can either reproduce racial
inequality
or reduce it i i think that's how it
works and um
it's it's very uh it's on the one hand
it's very simple
right because people can say what do you
mean um can i just be
not racist right and and that seems
that seems very logical to me but on the
other hand um
aren't there other things in um in
nature
that um it's either uh
like it's not static like it's either
moving forward or back or producing
energy or not i don't know i mean
i i've seen him explain it or listen to
him explain it that way that
it's just not binary when you do
something about when you vote on a
racial policy or a policy that has
racial implications
you're either going to vote to reproduce
that inequality or
or or mitigate it so i don't know man
i don't know it is it is quite a hot
button thing i i guess i'm in favor of
of saying that it's it's important to
have more nuance
even if you have that one dimension of
racist and non-racist
um maybe you can have some kind of uh
cross-cutting dimension where there's
another
value that matters right so okay you
might be voting for this policy that's
that's racist uh in its implications
right so maybe you're voting for um
voter id laws or something and you know
that it's going to
impact people of color more kenny would
say that okay that's a racist policy
you're you're you're being racist
but then on that dimension but then
there could be a
another dimension right where it's like
well you know i'm voting
for for safety or something right and
i'm being
um for safety or pro safety there's no
in between
and so you have like another dimension
and you can and so and so nuance can be
um
added to this discussion in that way i
believe
and so yeah i mean this is a very
typical academic move to complicate your
model by adding more variables to fit
all
the different possibilities but i'm in
favor of it i'm a typical
academic i like it um which i think
leads us to okay so i think that given
everything that that you've said
you know it's fair to classify your
views correct me if i'm wrong as
progressive
on social issues you know in favor of
social justice etc
but then you have this interesting
wrinkle where some of your attitudes uh
could be
uh described as socially conservative
and i think that
and as you as you point out this is
completely compatible with
other things i've read uh that's not so
uncommon
in african-american and other minority
communities
so is that an accurate way of putting it
and how would you sort of
elaborate on that um yes that that's
accurate i think that i think
most black americans especially um
working class and uh
and uh in poverty uh are are
socially conservative even middle class
actually so just black americans in
general
are are socially conservative but
economically progressive
and our social conservatism if i can
sort of
um indicate that by some kind of
policies maybe
um when it comes to things like uh
abortion uh we are
more likely to say pro-life
uh and and before you know i get
canceled i'm gonna explain what's going
on here so let me but let me go through
this word
so we would be more pro-life when it
comes to immigration uh
we're more um parochial we're more
interested in what's going on in our in
our neighborhoods
i'm saying our i got to give the caveats
always that you know this is just kind
of my
uh interpretation from personal
experiences and looking at
some survey data that anyone can get
from pure research it's kind of clear
these kind of these things
when it comes to gay rights uh um
uh famously black americans had to be
pulled along
uh for for gay rights with the
democratic party
uh prayer in schools uh even things like
corporal punishment so
so um i would say and and and
just yeah so so these are these ideas
are really
socially conservative ideas and um
although at this point in my life i've
kind of left that environment i still
kind of carry them with me so
but the way that this is often exp
it experienced within black america is
is a personal choice
it's never the case that we would sort
of want to
start a grassroots organization for
pro-choice
right or start aggressive like it's just
not it's just something like okay you
know what
if that person over there wants to be um
you know they don't want prayer in
schools or or they don't ask their kids
to pray
fine um uh that's their choice but but
this is what i want to do
and so i i think that that ex that
is very common within black america um
even for academics who are moving away
from that i'm not necessarily very
religious i know that you're you're an
atheist
atheist i'm not i'm not very uh
religious but i would con
call myself cultural christian but the
thing is the
um economic uh
aspects of life are so important until
you know those socially conservative
things are are nice but
we can handle that in our own home and
so we end up voting democrat
because uh because of of
things like you know lyndon johnson's
great society
and other democrats since then focusing
on
racial issues even if they're just
identity and not always uh helping us
economically but at least they recognize
that look racism
central issue in our lives right it's a
bit of an aside but
let me ask do you know anthony penn tony
penn at rice university
i don't know he was one of the very
first guests on my
mindscape i think he was episode three
or four uh and he
was he's uh african-american he grew up
a child preacher
uh became an atheist and is now an
atheist theologian
at rice uh who is really really
interested in this idea of
why more black people aren't atheists
right and and he says it's obvious why
because
uh the church is really useful to their
lives and their communities in a way
that atheism just
isn't and it's just not about arguments
at the philosophical level for or
against the existence of god and i
wonder
how that ties into this bigger picture
of um
he would be a great guest for your
youtube channel by the way
um but i wonder how this ties into this
bigger uh
question of cultural conservatism versus
sort of economic progressivism i mean
is it true that sort of both of those
attitudes
are responses or at least compatible
with
being disadvantaged minorities that you
know you want to be
have a strong family you want to stick
together and you also want uh
the economic goods to be distributed
more widely
oh that's true that's absolutely true it
even goes it's cross-racial
actually so you have a lot of uh
working-class and poor
white americans who are also have
similar attitudes like this and i think
uh
dr penn you said tony yeah is is correct
that it's it's functional
right um it's uh it's a way of providing
meaning for your lives and in a sense of
purpose which we we all need i always
wonder how
um atheists uh you know
what is the substitute for that thing
that i think we've evolved to
to have you know this meaning and
purpose but yeah
absolutely um it is a response to
um economic insecurity and poverty
i think that from a sociological angle i
can say
that and maybe you had someone else on
to talk about
the positive impacts of religion
but and i'm not talking about the truth
of it i'm talking about
just what it means for social outcomes
and it seems as if people who
um have some kind of faith
they they they tend to have more
positive social outcomes in terms of
income education crime overall happiness
marital stability so there's something
going on in there
that i'm not qualified to talk about but
but there's something happening
yeah no um tony penn's formulation is
that uh atheism
fails to provide a soft landing for uh
communities that sort of need that
social cohesion that religion
tends to offer and i wonder if it's even
um
i recently had joe henrik on the podcast
who's a harvard uh
anthropologist psychologist who talks
about weird societies
western educated industrialized uh
rich and democratic right and uh and you
know one of the things that we almost
it's interesting because the our literal
psychology
and brain physiology is affected by
these cultural norms that we
grow up in and the enlightenment and its
emphasis on individuality and
every person for themselves um is a way
of of living and being in some sense a
value system but it's not the only one
and you know there is an alternative
that says that
you know no i i should sacrifice a bit
of my individuality
to a bigger unit whether it's a family
or a culture or a nation or something
like that i don't think it's
there's an obviously right or wrong
choice here and i i don't know i wonder
how that is a vague question but i
wonder how that plays into what you're
thinking about here
well i i think i don't know i mean just
personally here this is not anything
that uh
i know in any academic sense but i mean
i i i feel like a sense of belonging in
a
and um the group provides a sense of
belonging and meaning
that you cannot generate on your own so
so
so this isn't about religion uh
specifically but it's just about groups
in general
and so you mentioned the enlightenment
and individualism and i think since uh
the
maybe the the 60s or 70s we've kind of
ramped that up even more so
the enlightenment may be a sort of
ideological
or idea based individualism like we we
should you know think as an individual
but i think we we now live materially as
individuals and
and that's a that's a problem i mean we
live in these homes with uh
we we feel that we have to get married
and and go off and have
two kids you know move you know 50 miles
from your
parents and live alone in the house and
that means that we're doing a good job
and we're happy
but i don't think we are i think there's
been there been so many studies showing
that
um once your material
uh needs are taken care of so like we're
in a wealthy society even the poor tend
to have
uh their basic uh needs met most of the
time
um so you so once you get that level of
hap of
material comfort then what actually
makes you happy is other people
and i don't think we push that enough
right we we focus more on okay go out
and
have a nice career and and all that
stuff and i'm not i'm not entirely sure
that's the right way
no actually i i'm very much on your side
when it comes to that and it's
but it's again it's one of these really
hard problems because i'm very much in
favor of
the right or the ability of people to
pick their jobs pick their homes and
their locations and even pick their
friends but
i i would i think i would agree with
what you're implying that uh
as a society we haven't constructed
institutions that make it easy
to find uh the right groups of people
who we want to hang out with
in formal or informal ways i mean maybe
is this a place where techno optimism
can uh
be raised again and can social media and
the internet and so forth
even if not now can they someday help
people
find their groups you know what i think
so
i think that as we so if you um
site like uh if you are talking with a
uh
uh healthcare professional and they've
got these like online
medical uh inter uh uh
consultations now and i've never been to
a a uh
a therapist uh like that but but they
now do it online and and
and from what i understand the
face-to-face matters
but even online teaching the
face-to-face matters because we're
sort of wired to take cues from what
other
from other people and so i can imagine a
twitter
that's not all text and gifs and short
two minute videos but it's actual
people who are like sharing a room
together
and maybe it's a permanently online room
or something and so you know it's just
open in the you know on your amazon echo
or something
and then you you can sit down and tweet
uh
a conversation and then you know i don't
know how this would work i'm just kind
of spitballing here but but the point is
that we could get to that point where we
can
we can simulate an actual uh
connection and not this sort of
digitized fake one
and it might tap into what we have
evolved to expect from
from another human being yeah i haven't
thought about this very deeply but that
sounds right to me and it sounds like
something that we don't do very
effectively but we could i mean this
might be
uh you know a future way of of going i
mean
i tend to suspect that you know as we
were talking about you know the
usefulness of black twitter
before i mean i tend to suspect that
this kind of ability of social media or
or the internet more broadly to connect
people is especially valuable for people
who find themselves in tiny tiny
minorities where
they wouldn't run into each other i mean
that's the downside of the
uh what i would call the downside of the
sort of culturally
conservative um vision of everyone has
their families and their communities and
so forth that
if you just don't fit in that can be a
really tough situation to find yourself
in
oh yes abs absolutely absolutely with
with some some psychological effects
if i can bring it back to uh uh the race
issue a bit
we find that middle-class black
americans who are in in white spaces
are suffering some impacts of uh racism
i think the harvard psychologist
david williams talks about this he would
be an interesting guest if he would do
it
he um he uh he he does this research
where he
he looks at the uh the high blood
pressure how high blood pressure
uh for black americans raises uh or
increases when they're in white spaces
and how this then leads to other
negative consequences down the line
that's right and it's because they're in
spaces where you know that they don't
have anyone
that they feel they can connect with and
so they die sooner i think his ted talk
was he he charted
a class from harvard that graduated in
1985 or something like that
and and he looked at uh or i guess
earlier than that
because the people had started dying and
he and he said well wow this is amazing
you know you've got
the same uh income you know as far as
you can tell
you know the the health behaviors were
similar but all of a sudden you've got
you've got black folk dying uh 10 years
uh sooner than white and uh and so he
he he makes the hypothesis that it's
because of racism raising high blood
high blood pressure that is very
interesting and it seems plausible to me
i mean i haven't seen
the research that the thing that i am
familiar with um
that sounds very similar to that is you
know a long time ago
i would have said that the idea of
single sex
schools you know for girls and boys
secondary schools or elementary schools
sounds terrible you're you're you're
taking people away kids away from
socializing with other kinds of people
etc
but then there are studies you have to
listen to the data right there are
studies that especially
in math and science uh girls
who take math and science classes uh
only with other girls
do better and come out of them better
and more
self-assured and more confident than
ones that are in co-educational
environments because then the boys just
sort of get all the attention and shout
them down
is the slick uh maybe accurate
explanation i don't know so
uh yeah so i i do think that um this is
one of those aspects which maybe
people who are skeptical of social
justice initiatives
would tend to downplay these sort of
difficult to quantify
but very much their influence you have
that is not
it's not like you're you're facing white
supremacists or misogynists or whatever
but there's this sort of
atmosphere around you that can just wear
you down and and cause deleterious
effects down the line
yeah yeah that makes sense and so i want
to go back to
um i don't want to quite give up uh the
conversation about the cultural
conservative culturally
uh christian attitude because like you
say this is not just you this is
quite common um among african americans
can we can we make it a little bit
sharper in terms of what it means in
terms of policies and things like that i
mean
what so you you say that you you're not
in favor even though you're pro-life
personally you're not in favor of
restricting abortion at the the legal
level are there
political decisions that that you go
opposite to sort of
uh you know elite progressive activists
because of your
cultural conservatism i would
uh i can see how faith-based
programs could help black america
especially in working-class communities
maybe for the same reason that um that
the guests that you had on talked about
i think that they are the benefits are
that they provide cohesion and we know
that social cohesion tends to reduce
crime uh
and and that is very important uh i mean
crime overall is going down so in some
ways this analysis is getting kind of
old but
certainly in the in the late 90s early
2000s
that was a a really big issue like these
petty
street crimes in black neighborhoods and
so the idea would be that
if you had more strong community
institutions
uh where young people but also uh people
of age
could sort of meet and communicate
and get to know each other that would
that cohesion would reduce
deviance so any kind of policy that
uh deals with that or or makes funding
available for faith-based institutions
and really we're talking about uh
churches here so yeah um but
but it it can also be uh you have we
have a lot of black muslims
so um but yeah faith-based uh
organizations
i i would certainly support that i think
that would be uh a good idea
and what is the current status of things
like that i mean i remember back in the
george w bush administration that was a
bit that was the hot topic
uh hot button issue at the time right
because they were definitely pushing
faith-based initiatives but i'm not
quite sure what has happened to that
initiative dead in the water yeah okay
so i so if i if i try to put words into
your mouth and then you can correct me
um you know the first amendment says we
shouldn't have government establish a
religion or congress should not
establish a religion and presumably
we're in favor of that but maybe there's
space
for working with religious institutions
in communities where that would be a
benefit is that the idea
absolutely because that you already have
those norms in place
i mean i could even imagine so i don't
know how
how this works um uh but i don't know if
if uh if catholic churches get
or or catholic schools get any funding
from the government i i assume that
universities do i don't know about
grade school or whatnot but but i could
imagine that
you may have a a a church that says okay
we want to we want to offer uh uh some
type of uh we want to start a charter
school or something
and we want to do it uh along these
particular principles
uh faith-based principles or something
well that's already going to be a draw
for the parents and and it's not as if
they're going to
just because they are offering
faith-based
teaching that they're going to be better
at teaching
but it might attract black americans
more and that institution is already
there
and so that might work that way um
but um back when george bush was doing
this i wasn't i wasn't a political
animal back then so i i don't know the
uh the details
of those things a lot of a lot of times
um
i i worry about
labeling certain things as um religious
or faith-based if maybe there would be a
better label
along the lines of principle-based or
morality-based you know um institutions
interesting
i mean i think you know when we talk
about faith-based exceptions
to certain laws or regulations uh it
seems
as an atheist that seems a little bit
unfair like what if i have a really
strong moral objection to something but
my
morals are based on uh something that is
just naturalist rather than theistic i'm
being discriminated against i'm being
oppressed
but i'm not sure how to actually make it
work in in in practice i don't know if
you have any ideas
i i don't but but that's uh but the the
reframing of it is great yes that makes
sense to me uh yeah
a morality based uh institution or
policy
or initiative uh certainly of course
that people would then say what do you
mean uh morality i mean
it's exactly my morality but but yeah i
still i still get what you're saying
i mean do you think that there is a
substantial disconnect between
what we might call progressive activists
who
think of themselves as fighting for the
rights of
black people and trans people
and whatever and the actual people who
uh might have different sets of values
is that a big
uh potential cause of friction within a
coalition that should be working to the
same goals
there is a disconnect but i don't detect
any friction yet
it's it's a it's the same disconnect
disconnect that you'd get in any um any
any type of
uh situation where you've got like the
idea generators
who may not necessarily be in that
situation
but you know they they're sympathetic to
it and so they come up with these ideas
and
uh you know they're in a think tank or
they're at a university or something or
they're in an ivy tower
and they come up with ideas that are are
consonant or i would say maybe even
parallel to what people in working class
environments think but they don't always
converge right
so so a classic example would be the
latinx
word yep so so the idea
that okay um that i
hope this is is right you know that
hispanic
is including spain and if you're from
latin america
then why do you want to be included with
people who
colonized you or or something of that
nature and so and so we want to use this
term latinx now
working class uh latinx
people hispanic latino and latino don't
necessarily care about that that much
but the general idea of respecting their
cultural
their their culture and understanding
that that probably uh
spain committed a lot of atrocities in
colonizing
uh that land they they agree with
right so that happens that happens quite
a bit even this
uh uh defunding the police idea
so working class black americans they do
not want the police out of their
neighborhoods right
i don't even think they really want them
defunded
but the general idea that police tend to
be over aggressive
in ways that you can't always measure
you know so so the
the the interaction between uh a white
police officer and a black male is
probably going to be more fraught
uh is more fraught including words
that uh that uh indicate how fraught
that situation is
as as as opposed to uh a white
police officer and a white female
there have been so many studies uh in
surveys and just anecdotal evidence
saying that look
and in comics actually i think dave
chappelle does this wonderful routine
where white folks generally have a more
positive view of uh
of police and that's historical and it
repeats over and over again
so i'm saying that because people in in
working black
black americans and and working class
neighborhoods
have a somewhat antagonistic
relationship with police
they would like police reform at the
same time
they don't want defunding because they
want the police there
so so it's one of those things where
there's a there's a parallel
um interests but they don't always
always converge
yeah exactly and i think that is you
know maybe it's just inevitable like
maybe that's just part of the game and
there will always be little tiny
frictions because different subgroups
will move
in different directions at different
rates but as long as we all move
in the same ultimate direction it's okay
so
i guess i don't have a final question
but let me i'll i'll sort of
say something as a final thought and
then and maybe try to get your
version of it or your response to it um
you know a lot of these when we think
about
activists trying to push inclusive
language like latinx
or radical ideas like defunding the
police
part of me says well i don't necessarily
agree
maybe i do but maybe i don't agree with
that specific recommendation
but their heart's in the right place
right they're trying to make the world a
better place
they're trying to fight for something
good and to me that counts for a lot
like i will respond differently to that
even if i disagree with it
then i will to someone who i think is
you know dismissing racism
as a problem where i think that not only
do i disagree with them but their heart
is not in the right place
and this goes back to where we started
in terms of communicating with people on
the internet
and choosing who to engage with and all
that i mean
maybe we can close with you talking a
little bit about your philosophy and
especially because i always like to
close on an optimistic note so i like
the fact that you're an optimist about
these things um
the attitude we should take towards
people we disagree with ideas we should
disagree with
um do you have a way of negotiating
those tricky waters
well when i communicate with people i
don't
always believe that i'm going to change
their minds
but i don't know if that should be the
goal really
i think i i think when you communicate
people the i
communicate with people the idea is
or the goal is to understand the idea
that they are communicating with more
nuance
and then to humanize the person that
you're communicating with
because it's often the case that you
know you you know you give the example
of the person
who might say racism doesn't exist and
and maybe they're
you know they're being disingenuous or
you know they're just not
communicating in good faith but if you
talk to them
long enough most of those people
um they they do have some id they have
some understanding of why that's the
case
uh so okay just to say like you know
fifty percent of those folks that
they're probably just you know
just bad faith but a lot of people don't
think that racism matters
right because they're they're they're
navigating their everyday lives and the
data that they're taking in
uh leads to this conclusion you know
that what are you talking about i have
no
antipathy in my heart everything's fine
you know my my neighbor's black i mean
come on this is okay you know
and so when you talk to them more even
if you think they might be wrong about
certain things
um you you see why they come to their
views their views and so that kind of
nuances their idea
and also humanizes them uh and i mean
come on this is a
democracy here i mean you should not
expect people
to just follow along with what you say
you know you try and you know
communicate and hopefully we can
negotiate a
uh path for moving forward i think it's
fantastic i think that was it's a very
good
uh way of putting it especially the idea
that
the purpose of talking to people is not
simply to change their minds right
sometimes you want to listen to people
you disagree with
just to understand them better and maybe
have them understand you even if no one
minds
no one's mind changes at all that's
still it's a goal maybe we forget
uh these days and so hopefully this
little conversation we've had
put some ideas into people's minds
whether it changes them or not but i
think it was a lot of fun so
rod graham thanks very much for
appearing on the mindscape podcast thank
[Music]
you
[Music]
you